- Bon, qu'est-ce que tu regardes
encore, là?
- "La ",
"Gaz Bar Blues", "Ding et Dong",
"Les voisins" : Serge Thériault
était l'un des comédiens
les plus en vue du Québec;puis u
des écrans radars.
Les documentaristes Martin
Fournier et Pier-Luc Latulippe
l'ont retrouvé.
PIER-LPE,
coréalisateur
- C'est sa conjointe, Anna,
en fait, qu'on a rencontrée
en premier, qui était dehors,
qui prenait un café.
n a un petit peu parlé
avec elle, on s'est présentés
et tout et elle nous a vraiment
informés que c'était impossible
de le rencontrer, pas dans
son... pas actuellement,
et surtout pas dans son ét
que ça faisait quand même
plusieurs années qu'il sortait
pas et qu'il voulait absolument
voir personne.
- En effet, depuis six ans,
les seules perso'ont
vu sont sa conjointe, leur fille
et un sympathique couple qui
habite dans le demi-sous-sol
sous son appartement et qui
tente de lui venir en aide.
- On te c'était
vraiment des bonnes personnes,
t'sais, puis on trouvait
que c'était rare de rencontrer
des gens avec un aussi grand
coeur, qui veulent tout donner,
puis à tous les jours,
puis ils écoutent les autres,
quitte justement à s'oublier.
- Ils ont entrepris
de documenter le quotidien
des proches aidants de Serge
Thériault et leurs démarches
pour le convaincre de sortir
de l'isolement. s
qui souffrent eux aussi
de le voir si mal en point.
MARTIN FOURNIER, coréalisateur
- En fait, la grande question
de ce documentaic'est :
comment on peut faire pour aider
une personne qui souffre, mais
qui veut pas recevoir d'aide?
- Serge Thériault est
omnipr le film
sans être devant la caméra,
comme une présence fantomatique,
lui qui n'a rien perdu
de son esprit.
d on a réud on a réud on a réudr
vraiment puis à passer un peu
de temps avec lui, effectivement
il n'avait pas perdu du tout
de ce qu'il est. Puisc'est c'es.
- D'admiré, oui.
- Puis de drôle et de naturel;
t'sais, il avait quelque chose,
il a une force. En fait, c'estqd
tu le rencontres vraiment.
- Au-delà du drame humain,
"Dehors, Serge, dehors"
est une ode au courage et à la
solidarité des proches aidants.
- Montrer la beauté et la bonté
des gens de coeur, c'est
ce qui est important pour nous.
Ces gens-là, pour nous,
c'est des gens de coeur.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens
de coeur sur la planète
et quand il y en a, il faut
les glorifier, il faut
leur rendre hommage.
- Le film "Dehors, Serge,
dehors" sera présentéaux Rencons
du documentaire de Montréal
avant de prendre l'affiche
à Montréal le 19 novembre et
de partir en tournée au Québec.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M